You're going to let me touch it with my hands.
Watch carefully only time in my life.
I'm going to wash my hands in diamonds.
We're now in the chief experts department and they have brought out some really
special diamonds for us, brought them out from a vault somewhere.
And I'm amazed by them.
This one here is the biggest diamond that is here.
It is 240 carrots,
but it's rather a shapeless lump. But down here,
there are some really amazing shapes.
I never realized that a diamond when it's not even
cut is a almost perfect octahedron.
It looks like out of the textbooks.
I just can't believe that nature can make a nothing quite so beautiful.
If you look down here, you can see this one. Here is the big yellow,
I think because of an impurity.
And then you can get some quite strong colors.
This one here is purple and this one is pink.
These ones here have grown into an almost perfect
cube. And this little one is really,
as far as I can see a perfect cube.
And then there's one that looks like a football.
Very important world cup was here in Russia last year though.
I don't play football myself.
And then there's another one that looks like a skull.
And if you turn it over it's hollow,
I think because it dissolved during the geological D
position may be in very high temperature, high pressure water that it dissolved,
but it's got a rather strange bowl shape with eyes
might be a bit grim having a dam and shaped like a scowl on your ring.
These ones here,
I think perhaps are the chemically the most interesting they're black
because they're a combination of diamond. And also graphite.
We have a box with 1,490
crystals of diamonds.
It's very interesting to me that they can actually count them so carefully.
You can see even these tiny crystals are all
octahedral. And if you look under the microscope,
you can see these little Octa Hydra.
I looked in the microscope, not very good in microscopes with my glasses,
but even I could see that they were really nice and crystalline.
This one here is the so-called twin,
where to optimize Kindra have grown simultaneously in
different directions. So you get a less interesting shape.
And at the same time, I was fascinated that in this one,
there's a crack diamond, such a strong material,
but even so sometimes it can crack.
And then down here is a,
an interesting crystal tiny,
but it has three twins. The two grown simultaneously.
So you have six octahedral all close together.
These are the different qualities of the diamonds.
Sometimes clearer, nicer shaped crystals than others. And again,
they have standards to make sure that they classify all of them
correctly because once you go to big box of them, if you've made a mistake,
you have to sort them all over again.
These diamonds are not completely pure company.
They contain traces of nitrogen. You can't see this with the eye,
but you can see it by using a UV light.
So Natalia,
we'll just put the biggest diamonds onto UV lamp and you
can see suddenly it gives out blue light and you can tell
that different diamonds, fluoresce, different amounts,
and occasionally you can get a different type of nitrogen
center, which instead of being blue is yellow.
So Natalie we'll show you one. Now one of the cubic ones,
and you can see it's a greenish yellow color. Again,
this is a really nice demonstration of spectroscopy and you could
analyze it even better,
looking through a spectrometer to get the precise wavelengths of the emissions.
So here you can see there's a nice blue, glowing octahedron.
Can we try the pink diamond?
You can see that one doesn't fluoresce at all.
So it probably doesn't have any nitrogen sensors in it,
or at least none that will absorb. But again,
this is a nice way of categorizing the different diamonds
so that you learn more about their structure. Learn more about that chemistry.
Let's try the pink diamond as well.
I think that's really interesting. The pink diamond fluoresces blue,
but you wouldn't have guessed that.
[Inaudible].
I'm in the sorting department where the raw diamonds have
graded. It's really amazing.
The diamonds that come here look rather like sand.
If you look here this bowl, I can just pull some out.
But what's amazing is that people go through this
literally grain by grain.
They have about 8,000 different grades,
which they know they remember, and they classify each of the grains,
according to the grade.
And here we have about 26 or
27,000 carrots in weight of diamonds.
The total value of this doesn't look very much is more than the million
dollars.
That's why people are watching me carefully and wearing a special coat,
no pockets.
And even these tiny grains look like little octahedral,
tiny crystals.
And you've got to remember that these grains have been obtained from a
solid mass of rock, which has been ground up and out of the rock.
They filter off these special diamonds.
And what's interesting here is that you can see different colors.
Some of the grains look a bit yellow,
some look really clear one or two gray.
So it's like my hair, perhaps my hair should be graded in color.
Okay.
Particularly interesting for me is that all of this is sorted by hand
because they are so valuable that it's worth people looking at each one
individually.
That's why every diamond should be to you really special.
It's amazing.
I've never seen anything like this.
It's unbelievable.
They're going to let me touch it with my hands. Watch carefully.
Only time in my life. I'm going to wash my hands in diamonds
Feels just like sand. It's quite strange.
It feels a bit like metal because diamond conducts heat very
well. So it feels as if I'm holding metal.
I think I could do this for quite a long time if they let me, but.
Still.
Here, you've got a million dollars worth of diamonds,
literally running through my fingers. Some of them are sticking to my hand.
We'll make sure you get them off. No [inaudible]
yes.
Thank you.
I think this is the most extraordinary thing I've ever done on periodic videos
and certainly the most fun,
the gold it's an exciting element.
It has interesting chemistry and it's just sitting here doing nothing.
It's enormously impressive, but it's a bit sad,
rather like a mausoleum.